Did you.
You make a goodness on in this area?
Yes. Yes.
[inaudible] we made all super heavy nucleus,
P E P.
Um.
North pole and South pole. Yes.
And the chamber between at [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
Actually,
this is so-called U 400 because the dye me close the poll is
200 centimeters. The iron source is hops too highly charged your,
either injected the vertical direction,
coming into the [inaudible] shoes.
The magnet into the chamber is extraction point over there.
And the beam Cami's this way. This is magnetic lenses,
which look like the optical layer is just to focus the beam.
And Dipo Margaret like that one for deviation and the separate piece.
Yeah.
This is a really historic Relic.
This is from the time that the Institute moved to here to Duke now.
And what's really interesting is to look at the heaviest element,
which is number 104, which in that time in Russia was called,
what was the name? Goodrich?
The heaviest elements was number 104,
which was called culture tourism. It's now called rather gym.
But that was before the you pack.
Work in Korea.
And I really like to see there's an old periodic table and the fact that
it's radioactive nearby and you can't even go near it is really exciting.
And of course, I'm next to URI. Again, this young,
the personification of element 118,
the heaviest element again, this song. So what's a better combination.
Could one have.
[Inaudible].
We're now on the top of the accelerator that was used
to make the super heavy elements, including a goodness song.
And this is the place where the project tale,
the calcium 48 with injected into the
accelerator course.
Big calcium is in the little oven inside here at
600 degrees centigrade.
And it comes in and you're using about one milligram each hour.
We were told one minute, go back to
Kelsey. Mine goes about five or six meters altogether from
here. Then it gets into the accelerator.
Then they speed it up to 10th of the speed of light.
And then they go off down the beam line
into the chamber where the target is and the beam line
is designed. So you get the maximum number of calcium Mayans to go through it.
So the really exciting thing is none of this has been shown before
on video. So you're the first to see it.
[Inaudible].
So we're now in the area where the elements are created.
So the big accelerator,
the cyclotron is behind that ball and the irons
come down. This pipe. The key part now is the target,
the target,
which is radiated where the two atoms come together
and fuse to make the new elements. But first of all,
let's look at the target. This is the wheel for the target. Exactly. I mean,
each consistent resection.
You have this one on the shirt and people are making targets section by section
one section picks one week. This target is titanium,
foil one-and-a-half microbes.
And then you put a layer of the kingdom or
[inaudible] to one micron. So you put backing for 1.5 micron,
does the beam go through the titanium first, the site of three periods?
So the beam goes through the titanium and then onto the big helium layer,
which is freeze so that any ions or atoms that
are formed can go straight out without any hindrance.
The wheel is going to run really fast, much faster than a CD,
and it's going round very rapidly so that no
particular spot on the target heats up too much because of the energy of the
beam. This is a target,
a windows of titanium that separates the high vacuum
of the cyclotron from the hydrogen atmosphere that is
around the target itself.
You can see that the beam really eats in to the window.
So it goes to this bright purple color.
But if you look at a new set of windows that are clean and silver,
This is where the elements are born.
You have to imagine the targets that we've just seen inside here,
but in a box,
the plastic outside is a sort of fume cupboard to pump
away any radio active gas or anything like that.
But inside is the rapidly rotating target every so often.
And it's really quite rare.
One of the atoms of the new element is formed.
And then that atom starts off down this tube towards the
detector.
This is the place where we detect the new
elements and it's the end of the journey for the atom.
So the atom comes down this tube and into the detector here,
the detector is a solid plate and the atom hits it and sits in the
solid and its decay is detected electrically.
And by watching how the element decays you
can then get evidence what it is because you can see it forming
daughter and granddaughter great-granddaughter elements and all of
those elements that already known.
So you can then work out that you've really got a new element.
And the decay is nearly always by emission of alpha
particles. It's a doubly charged helium nucleus.
[Inaudible].
Really very moving thing here because in this operator's
six new elements were created and
Eureka, again,
explained to me that they just put this together with pieces that they had ran
the lamp. And it wasn't something that was specially built.
They assembled it.
And it's been running for 7,000 hours every year for many,
many years and produce six elements.
[Inaudible].
You'll still have plenty left in the final nucleus and
calcium 48 has been the absolute key to the success
of these sentences of these super heavy elements in Duke. Now.